and they kept executing mike 13 straight
points at 13-0 run this the lakers first
lead since the first quarter
green will inbound simmons curry harris
nmb the starting five for philadelphia
and b trying to get free trying to draw
a foul curry has it
shot clock is off down to eight seconds
now harris harris against caruso
on the drive pull-up jumper it's good to
buyers harris sinks it
with 2.4 remaining lakers are out of
timeouts
caruso to davis dave is struggling
throws it up in the basket
and it's over oh a thrilling finish here
in philadelphia
as the sixers blow up quarter lead until
tobias harris
puts in the game-winner
[Applause]
harris with 24 points on 10 of 16.
and the sixers with a big victory
disappointing loss
for the lakers as they lose their first
road game of the season
who are the nba's elites battling doris
yeah and alex caruso is an excellent
defensive player
seth curry delivers the ball you're
middle of the floor
so one on one you've got greater size
able to get enough separation
and a pretty shot by a guy who's been in
a tremendous
shooting groove
harris back playing once again with jack
rivers played for him and the clippers
loves playing for rivers and here in
philadelphia
a terrific season 24 points seven
rebounds
and the game-winner as the sixers
able to get the victory
so harris capping off another good night
28 points for joel embiid as well
so the sixers win it final score 107 106
for lisa salters and doris berg mike
green saying thanks for watching
second game of our doubleheader coming
up next minnesota and golden state